[Musique]
ça y est c'est bon je me dis attention
parce qu'elles soient réunies juste pour
vous dire qu on est très heureux d'être
là
bac 6 mai
pour célébrer sa vaccination teresa 80
ans n'a pas fait les choses à moitié
tenue de la reine des neiges effets
spéciaux c'est résidents d'une maison de
repos belge est la star d'un clip tourné
par un éducateur spécialisé contre les
eaux
comme ça tu surtout les vieux on a
enfermé les jeunes et fermer les cinémas
les théâtres les musées et interdit les
concerts pour ouvrir les églises car on
est un pays laïc pour que les vieux qui
ont eu droit de sortir de l'ehpad à noël
ayala metz puisqu'on est un pays laïc et
comme dieu merci les salles de spectacle
ont été fermés il y avait moins de flux
de gens donc on a pu organiser des gros
flux dans les grands magasins et les
centres commerciaux
il a passé à la loupe les comptes de
trois cent mille clients d'une grande
banque française
l'économiste a comparé leur relevé de
2020 par rapport à l'année précédente
étonnamment les comptes des français
sont moins souvent dans le rouge
les soldes négatifs ont baissé de 14%
tout ça pour soutenir le personnel
soignant et pour qu'il y ait du monde en
réa parce que quoi de plus triste qu'un
lit vide c'est comme une salle vip pour
un artiste mais dieu merci les salles de
spectacles étaient fermés donc elle
risquait pas d'être vide ou pas assez
rempli parce que c'est vrai l'art quand
c'est pas rentable
ça fait chier voilà ça c'est 2020 il ya
un sorte de crétinisme dans cette façon
de fonctionner ce que j'appelle le
crétinisme présidentielle salaires
embête c'est la fable du lièvre et de la
tortue un leliève macro gambadent en dix
ans mais je suis le meilleur je suis
plus intelligent je suis même l'agrégé
d'immunologie on sait ce qu'on dit ses
courtisans et pendant ce temps là la
tortue qu'ovide elle avançait l'avancé
elle gagne depuis le début par ce mode
de gestion
nous sommes en retard en cette année si
spécial
les pagnes des français a battu des
records les montants collectés
atteignent des sommets
130 milliards en un an c'est deux fois
plus que d'habitude
qu'est ce qui vous énerve le plus ce qui
m'énerve le plus c'est que il va y avoir
des millions et des millions et des
millions de gens qui vont se retrouver
dans la mer ce qui n'a pas d'autres mots
c'est déjà le cas là en fait il faut pas
se tromper un la l'état paye énormément
énormément mais là on est en transfusion
c'est à dire que quand ils vont arrêter
les aides c'est là où le drame va
arriver il faut pas se tromper il faut
pas se tromper c'est la misère qui tue
le plus de monde c'est pas les virus qui
veut la peau de roger d'intermittent
parce que maintenant on est comme savent
tout nu chic
voilà messieurs c'est alors que si on a
l'air content dans la pompe
france 2 a fait un très bon score qu'aux
hier soir avec tropiques criminels mais
a été battu par tf
oui la non mais on y va pas nous faire
chier à temps a laissé vous c'est le
récit comment méfiez-vous capitaine
mario arrive mais oui je sais je sais et
avec la provoc elle s'est faite hier
soir corinne jaloux du monde si c'est
pas parce qu'elle vient le vendredi soir
face à koh lanta qu'elle s'est
déshabillé aux césar vous pensez que je
me pose la question
et au moment elle se retourne vers moi
et je fais nord le cap sont ils à rien
et je m'accroche je m'agrippe au cap
sont comme ça je le lève jusqu'au
nombril frais et puis il ya quelqu'un
qui a fait coucou par en dessous
est ce que je veux dire à quelqu'un qui
a fait coucou cesser ce quelqu'un chez
vous ou quoi une petite à vous laver
leur ont le lever trop sage à élever un
peu trop et tout le
le public a tout vu ma partenaire a
rebondi comme une championne enfin a
très bien rebondi dessus tout le monde a
beaucoup rigolé ça aussi c'est une
phrase bizarre est ce que la taille ça
compte la taille mais en fait il ya des
films de dix minutes qui sont hyper bien
deux films de trois heures qui sont pas
hyper bien donc michel c'est pas du tout
ça que vous deviez dire vous deviez dire
une petite [ __ ] c'est pas grave si les
cuisson rosée quelle claque bien contre
les fesses ça compense vous connaissez
l'expression avoir les poireaux qui
dépasse du cabba vous avez déjà entendu
cette expression c'était plus un neuf
je la trouve assez chic rue de redon
alors je ne sais pas si on va aller au
bout de cette émission aujourd'hui j'ai
très très peur je suis désolé voilà bon
appétit si vous êtes à table
je sais ce que je veux dire marina mais
en fait j'ai relu et je trouvais ça
embarrassant prévoir même un peu
vulgaire vulgaire c'est parce que j'ai
dit [ __ ]
ben moi dans ma bouche bée j'aime bien
alemanno
il ya des millions de gens qui sont en
train de perdre leur emploi leur
restaurant leur appartement ou leur
maison et quand même les gens restent
calmes parce que c'est la fraternité
donc on le fait on accepte 11 t on dit
ok on comprend pour la santé des gens
c'est normal on va le faire mais j'ai
l'impression que l'effort des français
pasche mans supérieur à l'implication
ceux de ce gouvernement
je me suis rendu compte que la chanson
c'était vraiment une grande dame
je crois que finalement les politiciens
n'ont pas compris grand chose il ferait
une nuée de tous chanter parce que c'est
incroyable comment passer un message
divinement bien à turbine
[Musique]
et que
absolument
on avait le schéma de ladoucette fils
parlons je suis désolé je vois qu'on
avait un coût non n'a pas fait tourner e
roland les invités dans la salle n'ont
pas de masque et le public un masque
c'est comme ça que l'instance qui est
installé là bas par exemple n'a pas de
masque comme ça à tout moment il peut
intervenir n'est ce pas constant et ses
livres et vous avez des choses pour
garder vous l'émission de brognard à
l'egypte à la télé hein c'est pas vrai
ouais ça alors c'est rare quand même
ben oui non juifs à la télé c'est pas
grave c'est un choix oui oui oui parce
que truc c'est nul
ouais c'est gentil merci et je sais que
apparemment n'est pas sorti de l'auberge
comme le dit jean castex mais on va s'en
sortir bye